many times we hear of AI news that we
only realize was significant in
hindsight this week came developments
that are big from any perspective I
don't just mean the whole new category
of use cases for GPT Vision or meta
bringing language models to billions of
people there's also autogen as the new
auto GPT what I'm calling the Altman
phone mistral's new 7 billion parameter
model Orca potentially replacing open AI
models at Microsoft and yesterday's
fascinating GPT fathom paper I'm going
to start with a use case for gpt4 vision
that I didn't see coming if you spot a
user interface online that you like you
can try to recreate it with gpt4 as at
Scarano demonstrated on X you can ask it
to imitate the layout and give you the
HTML code now I know many of you will
say that doesn't look too impressive but
wait until you see the next demo gpt4
with vision can iterate on its designs
because it can see its own output it can
recognize flaws and improve on them this
is from Matt Schumer CEO of hyperite AI
you can see it trying to design that
futuristic Google home page and
improving with each generation we've
gone beyond text feedback now into a
visual feedback loop I honestly wonder
if someone is going to do something
similar for Dali 3 use gpt4 Vision to
continue to iterate outputs until it
matches your prompt perfectly now the
next development probably won't impress
too many of the viewers watching my
channel but it might have a big impact
on the up to 4 billion people who use a
meta product or service we're talking
Instagram WhatsApp and of course
Facebook now I'm not gonna play you all
the promotional materials but
essentially they've got a bunch of
celebrities including Mr Beast and quite
a few others you can see here to put
their name to a series of 28 AI chat
Bots now I don't particularly want to
speak to anyone these people but I'm
sure that Millions if not billions of
people want to pretend to do so at least
now remember it was only yesterday that
character AI that deals in fictional
chatbots was valued at more than five
billion dollars and Zuckerberg is
clearly taking aim at character AI here
he is in the metaverse with Lex Friedman
I don't think anyone out there is really
doing what we're doing here I think that
there are there are people who are doing
kind of like fictional or consumer
oriented character type stuff but the
extent to which we're building it out
with the avatars and expressiveness and
and making it so that they can interact
across you know all the different apps
and they'll have profiles let's be
honest if the Apple Vision Pro takes VR
mainstream then a lot of people will
want to sit down and have an artificial
chat with their favorite celebrity and
it doesn't take much to imagine other
use cases now one group who can
definitely think of some use cases for
chat Bots is the CIA they are apparently
getting their own chat gbt style tool
now of course we already know that the
CIA monitors data that passes through
the us but there's so much of it that it
must have been impossible to sort
through with a large language model I
don't think that's going to be true
anymore so that's going to be useful for
catching criminals and the FBI is
getting this chat bot too but it does
remind me a lot of this article about
large language models being great for
State censorship for similar reasons it
would have been impossible for a country
like China to monitor all of its
civilian Communications but now as the
article says there is no real way to
prevent this it's only a matter of time
before well-resourced State actors begin
implementing and advancing such systems
but in later news yesterday we had this
from The Verge Johnny Ive of Apple Fame
together with Sam Altman of open AI Fame
are coming up with the iPhone of
artificial intelligence fueled by over
one billion dollars in funding from the
SoftBank CEO it would be open ai's first
consumer device and we might even have a
few clues about what would distinguish
it Johnny Ive has previously said that
apple had a moral responsibility to
mitigate the addictive nature of its
technology and according to the
financial times the project with openai
could allow I have to create an
interactive Computing device that's less
reliant on screens of course we saw this
week that chatgpt can now take audio and
visual input now apparently the
discussions are said to be serious so
let me know in the comments what you
would want out of let's call it the
Altman phone but now I want to talk
about autogen from Microsoft many of you
wondered if I'd been following this
development and yes I have been but
rather than just talk about what they
claim I wanted to try it out for myself
I had heard that autogen is poised to
fundamentally transform and extend what
large language models are capable of and
it would do this through multi-agent
conversations joint chats and agent
customization think of it as a more
sophisticated Auto GPT allowing the easy
creation of sub agents to achieve a goal
one of the agents or models could be an
engineer writing code another one an
Executor executing code or a product
manager coming up with the
implementation plan but to be honest I
was like I've heard of this kind of
thing before does it actually work I
discussed use cases with the amazing AI
architect Nico Gerald and we came up
with this demo a maths question gpt4
with code interpreter or Advanced Data
analysis almost always gets wrong for
anyone who's interested is in the style
of GMAT data sufficiency autogen was
able to easily create sub-agents to
delegate tasks to and it could break
down these compositional problems in
coding or here for example maths now the
autogen system can be run with a human
in the loop essentially as one of the
agents or maybe as the commander and
autogen can use tools and execute code
all these agents are essentially in a
group chat working together chipping in
when necessary or when called for by a
planner it got this difficult
mathematical problem right three times
out of three and yes this is just an
anecdotal demo I'm going to be doing
much more research on autogen and I'm
reaching out to some of the authors and
I do wonder if this would affect the
results I I found in my previous video
on reasoning in llms I must say that
autogen made me think again about this
recent tweet from Sam Altman he said
short timelines and slow takeoff will be
a pretty good call I think short
timelines meaning artificial general
intelligence not being several decades
away and slow takeoff as in not
exponential self-improvement on the
scale of days weeks or months when AGI
comes out but the quote continues but
the way people Define the start of the
takeoff may make it seem otherwise I
read that as saying that if you put too
strict a definition on what AGI means if
you continually move the goal post such
that AGI means the exact same thing as
super Intelligence being smarter than
all humans combined well under that
definition the moment AGI arrives things
could start changing extremely rapidly
but if we stop moving the goal posts and
admit that things like autogen could be
pretty radical now and that according to
definitions from say 10 years ago many
people would argue we have AGI now well
in that scenario you could argue we
might be in a fairly slow takeoff that
could be measured in years potentially
even more than a decade now of course I
might be misinterpreting his words but I
know that Philip from 10 years ago would
have looked at GT4 with vision and
auto-gen and been absolutely gobsmacked
and I do think that some combination of
the techniques that we have available
today together with scaling will bring
us to AGI that's why I would agree with
the majority of forecasters on metaculus
that the first AGI will be based on deep
learning it's free to sign up to
metaculus using the link in the
description and you get the double
benefit of seeing what other people are
predicting and also you get the chance
to put your forecast in writing that way
when you're right you get to boast in my
comments about how right you were thanks
as always to metaculus for sponsoring
the video and I wonder if the next
development is going to change any of
these predictions that development is
the release of Mistral 7B for 7 billion
parameters now apparently it outperforms
llama 2 13 billion parameters on all
benchmarks and based on my limited tests
with perplexity chat where you can pick
the mistrial 7 billion model I can
roughly believe that that is the
performance level it does make plenty of
mistakes of course here though you can
see it beating a range of llama models
including llama 2 13 billion on a range
of benchmarks as I pointed out several
times on the channel there are problems
with the benchmarks though and we'll
have to wait and see about data
contamination now mistrial does admit
that there are no moderation mechanisms
and I tried pretty much any example you
can think of and it always helped out
for pretty much obvious reasons I can't
even demonstrate the kind of things that
I asked and it happily replied to but
remember this is only their teaser model
much larger models are coming which I am
sure will be more capable and it's
released under the Apache 2 license
which is extremely permissive when the
mistrial models are further fine-tuned I
am sure we are going to see more
benchmarks broken but I would ask the
question does this constitute a race to
the bottom in which the company that
spends the least amount of money on
protections wins out of course because
it's only 7 billion parameters it's not
capable of that much but a future
Mistral 70 billion or 700 billion
parameter model might make headlines for
good and bad reasons but smaller models
do seem to be the trend with even
Microsoft looking to downsize as the
information put it Microsoft is trying
to lessen its addiction to open AI as AI
costs soar the article talks about how
Microsoft researchers are making
distilled models that mimic larger
models like gpd4 but are smaller and
cost far less to operate notably they
mention Orca and the Phi series of
models I am proud to have been one of
the first people to cover the Orca model
and my video on it called the model few
people saw coming was retweeted by the
lead author of orca of course I also
interviewed one of the lead creators on
the Phi series of models in a separate
video as the article points out the
fine-tuned Orca model performs much
better than the base model of llama 2
and as I remember the Orca paper
pointing out it performs nearly as well
as GT4 on certain tasks in fact now I
speak of it I remember predicting at the
end of the Orca video you can go and
watch it I remember saying something
like I wonder if Microsoft is funding
Orca to see if it can substitute for
gpc4 or the next GT5 actually now I look
back that was a pretty amazing
prediction indeed it looks like
Microsoft might well substitute Orca for
gpc4 for certain use cases particularly
as it uses less than a tenth of the
computing power that gpd4 uses but
speaking of being ahead of the curve
here is a fascinating paper that I don't
think anyone has talked about of course
that's probably because it came out
yesterday but nevertheless it achieves
part of what I talked about toward the
end of my smart GPT video about
systematically and fairly evaluating the
leading llms on a range of benchmarks
not this Patchwork of different
conditions benchmarks settings and
models that we currently have I'm hoping
to speak to one of the lead authors of
this paper but for now let me just give
you a taste of the highlights first we
have this epic chart and I want you to
focus on one part in particular at the
top right you can see the 1st of March
version of GBC 3.5 and then the 13th of
June version for GT4 we have the 14th of
March version and the 13th of June
version and the paper later describes
the Seesaw progress It's not a straight
line upwards in other words the
conspiracy that Chachi PT is getting
Dumber in some areas is actually correct
take the first row which is natural
questions performance went down slightly
between these two versions or trivia QA
for GT4 it went down slight and you can
look across the benchmarks to see the
same things happening and this is not
just noise as the paper later points out
the June version of GBC 3.5 saw its
score on math dramatically degrade from
32.0 to 15.0 that's compared to the
March 1st version in contrast on the
drop Benchmark Gypsy 4 performance
increases from 78.7 to 87.2 which is on
par with state of the art between the
two versions however between those same
two versions it score on a different
Benchmark plummeted from 82.2 to 68.7
this is not just noise and open AI
admits that when they release a new
model while the majority of metrics
might improve there may be some tasks
where the performance gets worse which
brings me to the web-based version of
gypsy 4 and chat gbt the paper notes
that the dated API models that's those
with the four numbers at the end
consistently perform a slightly better
than their front-end counterparts I I.E
the web version of the models to be
honest I had noticed dissimilarities
when benchmarking smart GPT they do say
that code interpreter now called
Advanced Data analysis has significantly
improved the coding Benchmark
performance getting 85.2 pass at 1 on
human eval so you're not hallucinating
when you see differences between the web
GPT models and the API models anyway
there is so much more from this paper
that I want to cover preferably after
I've spoken to one of the lead authors
but for now the video is long enough we
have covered some pretty epic topics
today if you enjoyed or learned anything
from this overview please do let me know
in the comments Shameless plug at this
point for my patreon which is also
linked in the description and as ever
thank you so much for watching to the
end and have a wonderful day